today we're going to be speaking with a
republican congressional candidate named
darlene swaffer and i think this is
going to be very very interesting for
our audience darlene is a small business
owner and is running for congress in
florida's 22nd district uh darlene i
really appreciate you coming on today
thank you david thank you for having me
yeah and it's you know i'm always
interested in learning more about
different candidates their ideas whether
there might be you know my audience is
is on the left and it's always
interesting to see where there might be
opportunities to sort of bridge divides
and work together and all of these
different types of things so let's kind
of contextualize your candidacy a little
bit um if i understand correctly michael
flynn and roger stone have both endorsed
you is that correct
that's correct and a few hours before
our interview you posted a picture of
yourself with the with the former
president donald trump and and you said
it was wonderful to meet my president
just as a sort of like gut check right
who's the current president of the
united states
uh i don't know that's debatable some
people feel that we had a stolen little
election and that's an illegitimate
president currently serving um you know
i have my own thoughts on that but
if you if you look back in the last uh
one year and several months where are we
as a country i mean we went from being
energy independent to now purchasing oil
from russia and negotiating oil with
venezuela
we went from having very low inflation
to having very high inflation
we got back into the paris accord even
though we are very responsibly
um
a global citizen on our energy
consumption well let's get to that but
darlene i want to hold you to who's the
current president
well
i don't believe that uh the current
president is a is a legitimate president
and we'll leave it at that is joe biden
currently the president even if you
think he's illegitimate is he the
president
i don't believe he is i don't believe
that is the current legitimate president
and who is the current legitimate
president
um
i don't i don't believe we have a
current legitimate president wow so in a
sense there's no president of the u.s
right now
i guess that's your interpretation of
what i said but okay
will you tell me i mean is there a
president right now i guess
um
well
i i'd rather not answer that how's that
because i kind of feel like you're
leading down an area of controversy
um that we don't have to go
okay interesting um let's talk about the
energy independence thing just to pick
one thing and so this i think will give
my audience a lot of kind of insights
into your into your campaign
um
the
united states in
2020 which was donald trump's last year
in office
produced as much oil as we used and i
think that's what you're signaling when
you talk about being energy independent
we used a certain amount of oil and we
produced an amount that matched that
and in 2021
the same thing happened we produced as
much oil as we used so can you tell me
on what basis you say that we are no
longer energy independent under joe
biden
well actually if you look at the graph
of how much oil we've purchased from
russia it's significantly more than what
we were producing for ourselves i mean
that graph was well published and i'm
happy to email that to you but that is
an inaccurate statement that you just
shared it doesn't matter how much oil we
consume we can either produce our own
oil
and build back our reserves which is
what president trump did
or deplete our oil reserves and start
purchasing oil from other countries
which is evident in the price of gas
today i mean it was under two dollars a
gallon a year and three months ago and
what are we at now four dollars five
dollars in some cases six or seven
dollars that is your evidence let's get
back to gas prices and i want to really
with you i love the clarity of the
conversation where let's let's agree to
first talk oil and then we'll talk gas
so
did you know that the u.s for decades
has purchased oil from foreign countries
so under trump even though we produced
as much oil as we used some of the oil
we produce we export and to make up for
that we import some oil and under both
trump and biden we imported oil from
russia did you know that
um did you know that in the last 20
years we had presidents in the united
states that did not focus on energy
independence and producing our own our
own oil and offshore those opportunities
to other countries did you know that
well but that's not an answer to my
question that is an answer because it's
not about the trump presidency what
trump did was create energy independence
to the point where we were exporting oil
okay that's not what happened in
previous uh presidential administrations
but you criticized joe biden for
importing oil from russia obama
administration and lies to the clinton
administration it allies to the bush
administration it was both democrat and
republican presidents that did not look
out for the interest of american
families and what trump did was put
american families first we have the
capability to farm our own uh reserves
from
gas coal and gas but darlene if we can
if we can darlene i really want to take
it one issue at a time i want to take it
one issue at a time
will you concede
that in both 2020 and 2021 u.s oil
production exceeded consumption will you
concede that and then we'll get to the
disagreement will you concede actually
it's not a concession we did produce
more
oil than we consumed but that's because
we were able to export it and actually
earn income
back to the treasury on what we exported
now we're no longer in an exportation
phase we are purchasing oil from other
countries because we're not producing
enough oil let's see i don't want to
belabor it but at the same time i want
to make sure my audience understands
where where we're disagreeing
in both 2020 and 2021 let's see if we
can even break it down more simply
darlene in 2020 the u.s used a certain
amount of oil well you will you agree
that we used oil in 2020 of course okay
we use oil will you agree we used oil in
2021
we did use oil in 2021 good
will you agree
that in both 2020 and 2021 forget for a
second about exports we produced more
oil than we used in 2020 and 2021 are we
okay on that
right but but hold on just let's uh
we'll get to it we'll get to it but we
agree so far right right okay in both
2020 and 2021 we exported some oil
right yes and in 2020 and 2021 we
imported some oil from russia
we imported very little oil i don't have
the chart in front of me but we did
import some right right and we had to we
had to produce more oil because our oil
reserves were depleted under the obama
administration
trump put back our oil reserves during
his administration would you agree to
that no i don't agree to that but let's
but let's get to that we'll get to the
disagreement so so far this is great
because we're really going through the
nuts and bolts we both agree
that in 2020 and 2021 the u.s produced
more oil than we used and we agree that
in 2020 and 2021 we exported some oil
and we agree that in 20 and 21 we
imported some oil from russia so what's
the big criticism of what biden did in
21 it sounds like it was exactly the
same thing
well actually
we didn't purchase oil to the extent in
2021 like we did in 2020 or 2019 oh so
biden was more independent he didn't
purchase as much biden purchased oil in
2021 that we did not as a country
purchase in 2020 2019 2018 and 2017. oh
he purchased four years under trump's
administration we did not purchase the
oil from russia to the extent of what
biden has done got it 2021. okay that is
fact okay all right let's talk a little
about gas prices
who's responsible for high global gas
prices right
now who's responsible for high global
gas prices if we are producing our own
oil
we can control the market behind the
prices
that's economics 101. okay
but so right now would you agree that
gas prices are high in the united states
they are extremely high my brother is a
truck driver with his own rig okay cost
over a thousand dollars
to fill his truck with gas
okay what does that equate to
he's gonna have a higher cost for
logistics for to transport goods got it
that's gonna translate to higher prices
of cost of goods sold absolutely higher
prices of retail
prices and then if you're purchasing
something that costs more today than it
did yesterday then you're paying higher
sales tax for it absolutely at the end
of the day we are all paying for more
on based on the decisions of the current
administration let's but let's let's
wait so
we agree gas prices are high in the u.s
do you agree gas prices are high in
france right now
well france doesn't produce their own
oil but that wasn't my question darlene
is do you agree that gas prices are high
in france they're not producing oil
they're at the mercy of supply and
demand of countries they can purchase
oil from fine
but my question is do you agree gas
prices are high in france right now
they're high everywhere all over the
world
beautiful so we can even skip that part
okay
is joe biden responsible for that
absolutely 100
how why did he stop production of the
keystone pipeline why are we not
producing the same level of oil that we
did during the trump administration
there's a zero excuse on why we can't
produce our own oil hold on a second
though darlene let's take it a step at a
time now because we want to be clear
keystone xl pipeline you know that
keystone xl phase four well i guess
let's back up
keystone xl is four phases
right three of the phases have been up
and running for years the fourth is what
we're now talking about agree so far
but hold on a second hold on a second
wait a second darlene wait a second okay
do you agree that phase four of keystone
xl was not active when trump was
president trump was trump wanted to do
construction but it wasn't active no of
course they weren't producing oil they
were not flowing the oil through that
pipeline beautiful agreed 100
do you agree that the pipeline is a
method of transporting oil not producing
it
that is a method of transporting oil but
that also reduces
the cost of supply and demand as well so
you have to factor that in what do you
mean how if they can get the oil to
certain uh markets within the united
states more efficiently that's going to
reduce the cost
of production okay and transporting
correct your economics 101 is a big
thing for you right we're okay
do you know
how much
global oil production would go up if
keystone xl phase four was completed
how much you would go up in what respect
give an example percentage-wise so if
right now we are what we would call 100
right now the status quo is 100 percent
if keystone xl phase 4 goes live
how much does oil production globally go
up
i don't have the answer to that it's one
percent why would you
why well i don't know if
that's your fact and i don't think that
fact is accurate no facts are facts
facts are not opinions a fact is a fact
it would go up one percent show me the
evidence behind that fact because i have
not heard that it would only be one
percent i actually think that's
radical liberal facts and people assume
that those are facts so share with us
what is your fact behind it's only being
one percent so
everybody from production everybody from
the nrdc
okay to
i mean it's you know
whoever you want to cite we're talking
about a one percent increase globally
that won't make a gas price difference
you know that darlene economics 101 and
actually i don't believe in that one
percent i believe that's the narrative
that they probably want everyone to kind
of run with okay so i i find it hard to
believe that a pipeline would only
produce one percent of the world
pipelines don't actually produce
anything they're just transport methods
it would allow the transport of one
percent more oil right you just don't
believe it
well share share the facts with your
audience share it with me and then we
can analyze it how's that beautiful
beautiful okay
um
what do you think the top tax rate
should be
the top tax rate i actually
i believe as citizens were
double triple and quadruple taxed okay
so
uh i think right now the federal the
federal
tax
is um
in the 33 percentile when you add
everything together what do you mean
percentile
well when you're looking at how you do
your taxes right yep
it's around 30 plus percent that comes
out of your income in terms of taxes
state
uh federal county any local taxes when
you add all that up together well it
depends what state you live in how much
you make and a lot of things right
correct i was an accounting and finance
major i did my taxes for many years so
it's around that that bracket
so you add medicare tax you add the man
you know the all the different taxes
about that much and then on top of that
you have sales tax and then on top of
that you have gas tax and then you know
if you smoke there's a cigarette tax um
and then you know when you die yeah
there's taxes everything there's taxes
on everything okay so and then when you
die there's an estate tax it's 35
if you have more than 10 and a half
million dollars
no actually it's less than that no it's
10 and a half million yeah
yeah no it's less than that what do you
think it is
well there's a death tax of like if i if
i die tomorrow
uh before my son could collect any
assets yup there's a death tax did you
know that that starts at 11 that starts
at 11 your first 11 million dollars
there's no federal estate tax
there's a death tax no
yes where'd you get that
um
there's a death tax that everybody goes
through when you die and you leave your
assets to your heirs right that's the
tax that is going to be assessed
by the government before your heirs get
any money but this is one of the big
this is wild darlene you're a candidate
and it sounds like you don't know that
the first 11.7 million dollars of one's
estate
doesn't you won't you only pay tax after
you leave 11.7 million to your heirs you
didn't know that did you if it's 11.7
how is it that my because i deal with
seniors all day long from the medicare
lady okay okay and i had it i had a
client that only had
250 000
and her estate was hit with a death tax
before her children collected it so how
did that happen with her maybe it was at
the state level i don't know but
federally there's an 11.7 million but
hold on but hold on there's you can your
first 11.7 million there's no tax
federally
right on the federal level okay but you
didn't know that two minutes ago right
right but that's on the federal level
there so my i deal with seniors all day
long that's what i do for the last 11
years and i've heard way too many as a
matter of fact this is the biggest
concern that seniors have brought to my
attention
that they have to set up a trust which
cost three thousand dollars typically to
set up about twenty five hundred to
three thousand yeah so that they could
try to protect their assets and not be
subject to that death tax before they
leave their children any money now
wouldn't that be the right thing to do
as someone advising seniors to let them
know that their first 11.7 million are
exempt
well i'm not a tax advisor so that's not
up to me legally to share that
information with them i sell medicare
health insurance so i'm not going to
give advice fair um that has nothing to
do with my life i think that's
responsible darlene but back to the
first question
let's focus in on the federal tax rate
because every state has different tax
rates different sales tax rates et
cetera federally speaking what do you
think the top tax rate should be
i know that there were some
recommendations where people said maybe
we shouldn't have any more than 14 or 15
percent across the board okay um you
know i i would love to see lower taxes
i'm for less government and lower taxes
so that's part of the republican
platform um and i'd love to see
everyone pay lower taxes i think that we
should have a much more efficiently run
government i think a lot of the three
letter agencies of four letter agencies
that we have on a national level should
be brought back down to the state level
i think there's a lot of duplication of
efforts so when you look at those
agencies and you look at the number of
employees employed by those agencies and
you eliminate
that
budget
that would be
a a completely different financial
picture on how our government could be
run more efficiently
in terms of the tax rate though you
would like to see the top federal rate
go down to 14
i i would like to see it less yes okay
and at what income would that top rate
kick in
i mean if you think about it
realistically
you know what and and i have different
look i i grew up poor okay i'm a true
raxa success story i run a very
successful company okay
and and i don't think it's easy for
anyone to live
a very uh
you know standard lifestyle if you're
making under a hundred thousand dollars
a year i just think that it's really
challenging with how expensive rent is
and mortgage is i mean and it's
difficult for any uh
single income household to survive i
mean if we're almost forced to have two
incomes coming into the home in order to
survive
so i would like to see the benchmark
much higher than that maybe above
250 000 maybe even more maybe 400
thousand i mean i i have some strategies
that i would like to implement
and this is to your point because i know
you want to stay on point but it touches
on taxes okay so now the average
american person that works a
blue collar job or professional job and
they're under that you know couple
hundred thousand a year mark when they
work overtime if they're an hourly rate
person if they work overtime why are
they working overtime they're working
overtime to pay down their bills right
pay down their student debt they're
they're working overtime to maybe save
money to take their family on vacation
i would like to see the overtime pay
not be taxed
i would like to see the income part of
it still be counted
when when you are looking into getting a
mortgage for example whether they need
to know what your income is in order to
qualify you for a mortgage so i still
want the income to count towards you
know social security income you know
applying for a mortgage applying for a
loan to get a car sure but the but the
payroll taxes
on the overtime pay i would like to see
that eliminated darlene that's a very
interesting idea that's a very
interesting i i'll be honest it's the
most interesting idea you've presented
so far i would say and it's not one that
i've heard before but that that's a very
and i'm guessing that this would be for
people earning under a certain amount
right we're really targeting workers
here yeah we're targeting workers that
are hourly paid but you know if you
think about it if they had that portion
that wasn't taxed
that additional income and revenue
increases our overall spending to me
that would even improve the economy that
would approve improve you know people's
ability to eliminate their debt to you
know try to get ahead in a way so i mean
i would just would love to see that idea
implemented i also have other ideas with
regards to reforming medicare and
improving solvency because some experts
are predicting that medicare is going to
be insolvent in about two to three years
that's such a big topic let's not dive
into that right now but at least that
one idea you had that's a very
interesting idea in the last few minutes
we have um q anon in 2019 you wrote a
lot of q and on stuff on your facebook
page
you talked about how q inspired you to
run for congress in 2020 talk to me
about q anon have you taken a so-called
q and on oath
um i didn't write a lot of q anon posts
that's inaccurate um i have a lot of
friends that are you know they call
themselves digital folgers okay and i
actually said that they inspired me to
run for office because to me i feel that
you know we as americans we need to
learn the truth and they say q and on
oath there was no q a on both it's the
oath to protect the constitution against
enemies foreign and domestic so how do
they attach a cue
conspiracy
idea behind taking the oath to defend
your country i actually find that
insulting okay and so yeah it was
general flynn that asked everyone to do
that oath and if you look at my oath
because i did do the oath
i also asked for god's protection and
blessings over our country that was the
end of my oath
my so-called oath got it but you know i
took that oath because you know my fifth
and six grandfathers fought in the
revolutionary war in the war of 1812 and
my uh eighth-grade uncle is benjamin
franklin well what did benjamin franklin
do
when he signed the declaration of
independence he said
we either hang together or we hang
separately but we most assuredly will
hang so that's where the term we where
we go when we go all came from john f
kennedy had that on his boat okay john
president john f kennedy had that saying
on his boat so why people are
attributing that to a conspiracy that's
lack of knowledge on everyone's part and
they're running away with that so in
other words so you are not a believer in
q anon
i've never said i was that's all
conspiracy related media trying to bash
an america first candidate well this is
why i want to ask you direct so you're
saying you do not believe or subscribe
to q anon
no i i have friends that do okay and i
support anybody trying to find the truth
understood understood that that's uh
that i think is very very important to
know
um okay darlene listen this has been
incredibly illuminating and i can't
thank you enough i think we've had a
number of disagreements you had the one
very interesting idea there about not
non-taxable overtime hours very very
interesting i can't tell you how much i
appreciate you spending some time with
us today
thank you i appreciate that too and i'd
love to see the facts behind what you
shared one percent how that's going to
add to the oil supply i know that's
inaccurate but we'd love to see the data
on that when we publish this maybe your
sources are inaccurate and you don't
know so i'm going to look into it too
and whatever i find i'm gonna send it to
you please darlene it's been an
unfettered pleasure on our end
all right thank you thank you so much